on peut faire beaucoup de choses avec
des épingles même les illustrations d'un
livre c'est le cas du docteur jivago les
200 illustrations sont toutes nées d'un
million d'épingler enfoncé dans un écran
d'un mètre carré
conçu par un peintre parisien alexandre
alexeyev le procédé vaut d'être dévoilée
les épingles font saillie d'un côté de
l'écran si on enfonce une sous un
éclairage particulier elle fait naître
en ressentant de l'autre côté une tâche
sombre en enfonçant plusieurs on obtient
d'un côté une figure clair de l'autre
une figure sombre identique
première opération au verso madame
alexeyev au moyen d'un rouleau enfonce
les épaves au recto simultanément
apparaît donc une bande une forme et
mensonges c'est sur cette grande qu'alex
eev va travailler en enfonçant certaines
départ il dispose pour cela d'un
instrument de touche de toute forme un
anneau il lui suffira de l'appuyer
d'une certaine façon et ce sera la lune
un autre à nos eaux calmes lure en épis
de blé et une à une
apparaîtront les branches d'un sapin
pour finir un rouleau parsemé de trous
et de bosses et c'est maintenant
l'apparition des flocons de neige
ainsi par le simple jeu de l'ombre
portée des épingles plus ou moins en
français tout un tableau et n'est qu'un
coup de rouleau effacera mais auparavant
il aura été fixée sur une plate faute
aux graphiques là n'est pas limité le
procédé d'alexandre alexeyev par les
variations de la source lumineuse et en
appliquant le principe du dessin animé
il a pu aussi image par image donner la
vie à un mode mairie c'est ainsi que
sont nés voici 25 ans les fantasmagories
d'une nuit sur le mont chauve un des
classiques du dessin animé
orgueil de toutes les cinématiques
à